Speaker 1: Let's hear from people in the audience
on the Friday show.
We go to the phones, except we really don't.
We actually use discord.
You can join the David Pacman, show discord,
absolutely free at David Pacman dot com slash
discord.
And it's really an extraordinary thing as
a reminder to everybody who's waiting.
The format for your nickname if you want to
talk to me is name and location or location
and name.
Those are the rules.
So, for example, we're going to go to Junie
from Florida.
Junie from Florida is our first caller today.
Junie, what's going on?
Speaker 3: Hello? David, Do you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I do.
Speaker 2: Great.
Great.
My question for you is what?
Everything you know, going on with the current
Republican Party, with, you know, banning
books and trying to restrict voting.
What do you think is the future of the Republican
Party, in your opinion?
Speaker 1: Well, I don't think it's determined
at this point in time.
I as I've said for a while now, it looked
like the 2022 MAGA red wave wasn't going to
materialize and it didn't.
And the question now is what happens in 2024?
There really doesn't seem to be anything that
will stop Trump from being the Republican
nominee short of Trump himself.
And what I mean by that is one arrest so far.
$5 million sexual assault and defamation,
a verdict against him on Tuesday, potentially
Another arrest coming out of Georgia in between
July and September is roughly what's estimated.
Could all of that take him off the campaign
trail in such a way that he's just not viable?
But the Republican Party for now does seem
to still hold Trump as its leader.
And I don't know what's going to prevent him
from being the nominee.
So then the question becomes becomes the 2024
general election.
Obviously, if Trump is reelected president
in 2024, which I don't think is as farfetched
as some do, Trump's actually ahead of Biden
in some polling already.
If that happens, then I will be ready to say
the Republican Party in a more permanent way
has jumped the shark, for lack of a better
term.
However, if Trumpism is again defeated in
2024, assuming Trump's the nominee but loses,
I believe at that point, particularly with
Trump being an even older guy, at that point
in time, it will be essentially open season.
On abandoning MAGA fully by the Republican
Party, which may be what saves them at the
end of the day.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Yeah, that sounds.
I, you know, I, I agree with that.
And you.
Do you mind if I just ask you one more quick
question?
Sure.
Do you think with the Republican Party going
against, you know, the LGBTQ community, stigmatizing
them in very, very negative ways?
Do you think it's fair to maybe called the
modern day Republican Party fascistic or proto
fascist in a way?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I think, you know, with a
lot of this stuff, these are mostly linguistic
conversations then than operational or policy.
But I think there is no question that what
you're seeing among the MAGA movement is a
sort of neo fascist lite authoritarianism
of sorts, which would like to be much more
hardcore if we didn't have some of the checks
and balances we have in the United States,
they'd likely succeed in becoming much more
of that.
But I do think that wannabe fascist is probably
as good a term as any.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Agree with that.
Well, okay, David, that's really all the questions
I've had and I don't want to hold up.
So, you know, I'll just let you get to more
callers.
Speaker 1: Well, one question for you is Johnny
Short for something?
It's not a name I'm super familiar with.
Speaker 2: Oh, no, that's okay.
It's a it's a nickname.
I go by because my name is Leroy McGraw Jr.
And so Junie just comes from Junior.
Speaker 1: Got it.
Okay, very good.
That makes that actually makes a lot of sense.
All right, Jack, thank you for
the call.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 2: No problem, David.
Enjoy the rest of your weekend.
Speaker 1: You, too.
There goes Junie from Florida.